some really cool and surprising
notifications
all right so thank you very much
so I'll be talking about uh some
applications of of obfuscation and
related Notions and uh so this is based
on three different works with uh uh many
excellent collaborators and so the title
of this talk is is Tales of obfuscation
but really uh
I for me the title of this talk is
different
uh
uh title of talk for me is why I stopped
wearing and learn to love uh office
Topia so and hopefully I'm sure many
people are already here already love
optimistopia maybe I can uh convince
maybe more of you that the office Topia
is the world
[Laughter]
okay
so what do I want to talk about in this
talk
I want to tell you uh about
how to apply obfuscation some recent
results about using obfuscation in
various areas of theoretical computer
science now
in particular there's going to be kind
of five questions in each one of uh in
these areas that I'm going to talk about
how you can you can solve some open
questions
using obfuscation and for now let's not
worry about what the what the questions
are uh but we'll we'll see them later uh
differential privacy de-randomization uh
logic or bounded arithmetic average case
complexity and medical connection
and so when I Was preparing this talk uh
I was kind of thinking to myself okay
what's my goal what do I want you guys
to take away from this talk
and um
so in The Lion King
uh Pumbaa
talks to uh uh Simba and he says these
two words will solve all your problems
or at least this is what people think he
he said
um but if you listen really closely the
two words that will solve your problems
is actually
indistinguishability obvious case you
gotta listen closely uh 1994 so this
actually the predates for rock at all
um
and so this will solve all your math
problems and distinguish the obfuscation
oh oh yeah can you sing the song
so karaoke night is uh there's a karaoke
event tomorrow Thursday 7 P.M I think
Stefan is organizing it I don't know if
he's here
um you should all come and if there's
demand I will I will sing it for you
actually
um
yeah I think what is it there's also a
line in here that's like in the song
that they're like uh
it's a problem-free philosophy
[Music]
if you're a philosophy so my goal for
the complexity theorists at least or or
people who are not cryptographers you
know you have a problem
at least think you know whether
indistinguishably obfuscation will be
able to solve it I think this is a good
Takeaway on the other hand you know uh I
guess cryptographers have realized this
for a decade now you know yeah I'll
probably get some distinguishable
notification for you guys
oh I guess it's a little bit cut off
um
uh my
oh
my goal is you know a disclaimer I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna give you like fully
formal theorem statements or and some
things I'm not even gonna fully Define
my goal is to convey to you okay what
are these questions that are being
answered without obfuscation and I
really want to give you like two ideas
uh two nuggets that I think you know
might be useful somewhere else and
hopefully that you will enjoy so that's
my goal for the talk
foreign
to start off I want to I want to talk
about uh uses of obfuscation and logic
and de-randomization and also a little
bit of applications and income Networks
and so to do this I'm going to give you
some background on some of the problems
and questions in this area and then uh
at the end of that I'll recap what these
questions are before I tell you what
obfuscation says about them
so the first thing is about this problem
called range avoidance which is a really
nice problem introduced by Klein word
court and metropolsky and papa dimitrio
they were interested in total function
problems in the polynomial hierarchy
so the problem is as follows it's a very
natural I hand you a circuit
and this is a big length expanding
circuit it Maps n Bits to n to the 100
bits actually the N to the 100 here
isn't so important it needs to be some
larger than n it's kind of the most
interesting case is large polynomial
again so it's some length expanding
circuit
and your goal is
output some string
that is not in the range of the circuit
so uh I want to stress you know this you
know at least in this setting of
parameters this is a like a huge number
of valid outputs you know there's two to
the N to the 100 I guess when n is two
this is like greater than the number of
the atoms in the universe or something
like that uh minus two to the end so
there's a huge number of valid answers
uh are there any questions about this
Okay cool so this is a total function
problem they'll always be an answer
can anybody give me an algorithm for
this
okay so you don't have to think very
hard uh
some people yeah exactly very good and
uh depending on how you define fbp which
is function version of VPP this means
that like a void is in fvp okay and this
is like a really simple algorithm you
actually don't even have to look at your
input really you just need to know how
many bits you're mapping to pick a
random string boom you're here you've
solved the problem
um okay but that was really easy yeah uh
can anybody give me a more advanced
algorithm and
this is a good idea
okay all right go come back please
um
okay all right let me let me make it
fast simpler for you uh what if we talk
about like ac0 circuits let's say this
is an ac0 circuit perhaps n Bits n to
the 100 bits now you want to find
something that's not in the range
at the truth table of parody
um yeah I don't think so I could just uh
yeah
um hit it with a random restriction
simplifiers decision tree and then just
see oh it's a family decision for
yourselves you can do this you'll get
some savings you get a little bit of
savings but actually
um you're not going to get very much
savings off of Workforce by doing this
and in fact even for nc0 circuits
uh we don't have a better algorithm than
this
if you go if you if you go down to nc0
oh an nc0 circuit means every output
depends on a constant number of inputs
constantly screws it down 100 right yeah
okay this is caveat uh and uh okay or
okay let me not actually let me not get
into this into this too much for General
mc0 circuits okay this is what we know
or what we knew
yeah good question I want to answer that
uh it depends if you ask Ryan or Scott I
guess uh
this was a story you can ask me if
you're interested
um okay so there's an fpp algorithm
whatever that means uh okay what's the
first question you would ask is is there
a deterministic algorithm for this okay
who thinks uh that there should be a
deterministic algorithm oh efficient
yeah I guess there is raise your hand if
you think that there should be a
deterministic out of this
[Laughter]
okay good
so the audience seems to be next week I
think is uh is good reflected uh at
least there's this quote from win-wing
and santhanum it's unknown whether a
void in function version of NP or
function version of B is implied by any
plausible assumption we're not even sure
what the grand truth should be so this
is this is a open question
de-randomization
hopefully up and uh I'll tell you a
little bit about how you can use
obfuscation to try and understand this
question this is kind of like the first
question
and um
moreover this this question it's
interesting in itself okay here's a
natural problem you know uh can it be
can we solve it deterministically oh
okay I forgot about this I want to give
you guys a puzzle
um are there things in fdpp whatever
that means that are not an FP like uh
yeah yeah okay uh
yeah Russell so uh this is actually due
to some like um
yeah exactly so here is a here is a task
which is solvable with Randomness which
is not solvable deterministically which
is output a komogorov random string and
this isn't like time-bounded or
something anything like that this is
like the regular Commodore complexity
which is like an uncomputable notion it
turns out that like uh there's no way to
generate these things germanistically so
depending on how you define fpp which is
why it's like a somewhat controversial
thing uh this is an example of a problem
that can be solved with Randomness but
not uh solved deterministically but of
course it's like related to some
uncomputable notion uh but this tells
you maybe okay you should be a little
bit cautious about I have a randomized
algorithm what can I get a deterministic
is the question
oh yeah you do diagonalization hey it's
not in Ft
do diagonization to say that say that
what is that oh avoid is not enough to
avoid algorithm into itself
okay I'm not sure we could talk about I
I'm not sure what the uh I don't think
so but uh maybe I'm not understanding
what you're saying but we can come back
to it
um
okay so deterministic avoid algorithm
you know it would uh it's it's
interesting for its own curiosity but
let me ask you if I had if you had a
deterministic at all void algorithm
could you do anything interestingly
this is for anybody in the audience who
doesn't already know the answer uh maybe
what could you get if you had a
deterministic avoid outcome does anybody
have an idea
read it to yourself
three randomization yes but actually I
think I you'll get something even more
powerful you'll get a field medal uh and
actually even better than a Fields medal
you will get a hundred dollars uh owed
to you by Paul Erdos
which is I don't know it depends what
you care about but uh so it turns out
it's deterministic of void algorithm
exactly as evil pointed out uh gives you
breakthrough explicit constructions and
combinatorics in particular there are
these various tasks I don't even want to
tell you really what they are but
construction
of excuses
um uh this is the 100 air dose problem
which is uh uh construct explicit Ramsay
graphs uh other things like rigid
matrices Randomness extract anyways
there's all these various objects from
Torx if you have a deterministic avoid
algorithm then you can actually
construct these things and this is
something we don't know how to do this
is kind of a deficiency in complexity
Theory we don't know how to uh we don't
have an assumption that says oh if this
is true then we can construct uh Ramsay
graphs or uh explicit range of graphs we
do know you can construct a small list
of objects one of which is a good Ramsay
graph you know we don't know okay this
thing is going to be a good Ramsey graph
so how to get strong enough I mean I
don't know it's all verse papers that's
what he says
does it count if you have a list
that one of which no it does not it's
it's precisely a deterministic algorithm
for this problem you only get to Output
one which is why it's different yeah
when you say explicit uh truth tables
uh it's like uh some hard functions in E
uh yes
but if you want to write down a truth
table it's length two to the end right
so if you want to produce it
it's it's probably what you mean by it
okay
because you can't have a circuit for
something that doesn't export circuits
right
okay
um all right so that's another topic
I've covered
de randomization I'm going to summarize
these questions again so you don't have
to hold them in your head I just want to
point out that these are different
topics so like you shouldn't be looking
for connections between them here is
another field of uh theoretical computer
science it's founded arithmetic it
studies logic it's uh interested in okay
if we have certain axioms uh how hard is
is it to prove certain statements how
what is like the length of the shortest
proof to prove certain statements
and there's this kind of uh open
question that's been open for about 20
years this is a question asks in fact if
you're familiar with proof complexity uh
he was he was interested in he defined
proof complexity generators whatever
that means in order to try and answer
this question which is does some proof
system pb1 prove to do a weak digital
organs
so pv1 is is just some logical system we
won't really care about it for this talk
which corresponds in some sense to
polynomial time reasoning so Steve Cook
defined it uh and it's reasonably
powerful it can can prove the PCP
theorem
and the Dual week pigeonhole principle
is is sort of like a logical statement
that's related to a range of Weights it
says if you have n pigeons in two n
holes there's an empty hole it's like
the lonely and lonely pigeonhole uh
principle and the motivation for this
question is kind of like one of the
fundamental
questions and proof complexity is is can
you prove lower balance efficiently like
uh is the reason is there efficient
logic which lets us show that like
statements related P to P not equal to
NP and somehow this is kind of like a
first step to showing this or at least
this is the
the ideas
at least along one line of research you
can view the Dual weak pritch and whole
Principle as like a baby baby version of
trying to prove the hardness of proving
lower bounds
so okay
to summarize I've told you about three
questions in three different areas of
theoretical computer science these
questions are related to each other uh
de-randomization is there a
deterministic algorithm for range
avoidance combinatorics can a complexity
assumption in particular the range
avoidance thing uh imply explicit
constructions and something about logic
are there efficient proofs of the Dual
weak vegetables let's do that question
my goal in this talk is to make you
understand what the context of the
questions are uh so that's what I'm
shooting for
shooting for and so
in this first result which is joint work
with uh jatu lee who is uh he's an
undergrad at qingwan will be a grad
student at MIT and uh Ryan Williams
who's here in the room you can show
under plausible assumptions I'm going to
tell you what they are in a second
actually there's no efficient
deterministic algorithm for everyone
and pv1 cannot prove
and in fact this this gives if you're
interested in proof complexity kind of
the first separation of like this
somehow corresponds to
efficient deterministic reasoning and
depending on who you ask this
corresponds to probabilistic uh
efficient reasoning these two Notions
are actually kind of separated under
these assumptions
okay
so I've said a lot of stuff my goal I'm
next is to get
one nugget from this proof but are there
any questions
comments
both of it's an end oh oh under yes both
of them
okay good
okay so now let me try and give you a
nugget
so
what let me ask you
what do you think I've told you now that
this problem uh is hard to solve
deterministically
what might be a hard instance of a void
a title of this talk is a hint
I think we have an idea
foreign
that's interesting maybe this is related
to what you're thinking about this is
this is not the direction I was thinking
again I maybe we could talk later and
maybe there's something interesting
there but was there another suggestion
trf prg oh so you're saying um
you're saying okay what if we if we have
a prg should this be a hard instance of
a boy uh is that what you're saying
actually this is a very good intuition
in fact this is a major complex major
conjecture in proof complexity this is
this thing called like proof proof
complexity generators you know which
basically says that for natural prgs
it's hard to prove that something's not
in the range of the prg in fact this is
like rasporov has been championing
championing this for a long time uh okay
this is another good idea but how are
you going to prove the security of that
obviously
if you obviously hit the prg this is
also a good idea uh how are you gonna
improve the security
right
okay
yeah these are all good ideas I actually
I was thinking of a different attempt
one so I'll tell you that different
attempt one which is uh what about a
random Point function
so you you uh
you you pick some random X star you pick
some random y star you obfuscate the
function that's y star and X star and
it's zero otherwise
you know uh you could hook yeah if this
obfuscation is really a really really
good obfuscation that uh it's hard to
actually print something that's not y
star
did the intuition for that make sense
unfortunately like okay I have no idea
how to or at least a priority I have no
idea how to prove this because like okay
almost all the even if you had BBB here
like there's a randomized algorithm for
this right like how are you going to use
your assumptions to distinguish between
a randomized algorithm existing and a
deterministic algorithm existing it's
not clear how to do it
so here's the Nugget oh are there any
comments before
the algorithm inside put the algorithm
inside so the first case you'll see that
it is
so you're saying okay I have an
algorithm for a void
and then I obfuscate that and then I run
avoid on its
thank you
I mean you're increasing but maybe
oh yeah I don't know how to make this
work but yeah we can talk about it maybe
there's some yeah it's like it's just
yeah well just a question are we
specifically talking about circuits or
two machines we're specifically talking
about I think that circuits would kill
the uh the uh recursion yeah yeah okay
otherwise
I see I see yeah yeah we're specifically
talking about circuits here
okay so this is attempt one yeah I don't
know how to prove this a priori
um
so the kind of the Nugget is
add another assumption and this is an
assumption that's not cryptographic that
NP is not equal to co-np
and then instead of obfuscating a point
function you look at something that's
kind of related to witness encryption
you say you have some uh set arbitrary
set instance by you pick a random y star
and now you obfuscate a function which
is a y star when the formula is
satisfiable and uh zero when it's not
satisfiable
and it turns out you know okay there's
work you have to do
um but this actually you can prove is a
hard instance at least some of the time
under this NP not equal to Columbia
assumptions this is the Nugget I want to
convey and uh you know I think it's
interesting the idea of combining uh
like a a worst case complexity
assumption uh with these cryptographic
ideas and I hope maybe it can be used
somewhere else foreign
yeah so what you say is
um
yeah I guess like what you'd really want
to say is okay and a hard unsatisfiable
instance but I don't want to Define what
like a hard unsatisfied you can imagine
I want to say there's no algorithm which
is always output something that's not y
star for all fee for all of f star
but hopefully I didn't do this make
sense
let's see instances uh chosen I mean how
does it be chosen so yeah how have you
chosen uh what okay let me let me tell
you what the what the final theorem is
so you say assuming sub exponentially
secure IO and assuming NP is not equal
to currency actually if you want the
second result you need something
slightly stronger than this but
basically the same you can show that
there's no efficient deterministic
algorithm for a void so actually what
the construction does or what the proof
does it says okay suppose you could
solve a void of every instance of this
form so for all the uh then you can
actually prove that NP is equal to
assuming
but the Nugget I want you to take away
is combining
potentially interesting to the point I
mean I guess you don't want to say is
the point is that if someone
um outputs y star on the Suffocation
then you know that the circuit is uh not
satisfied you know the circuit is not
telephone exactly okay so this gives you
complete destination uh the harder
direction to sound this but if you think
about that for a bit more okay but good
excellent
so can you repeat that what is the wise
uh chosen by random by star the previous
yes this is like
this is the thing that could be output
by F so you just pick some random y star
this is
three questions
uh sorry
just learning something perfect
oh yeah because this okay and your end
goal at the end of the day is to come up
with an algorithm for uh oh you know the
other story yeah yeah so you want to
prove that something is unsatisfiable
and so then you you see does there exist
any y star such that it returns itself
yeah so you get you you uh you know it
foreign
ization uh it turns out that so this
answer is no recombinant Torx you know
you're going to need a new idea there
are some new ideas for this I think this
is a kind of very interesting question
even from like a cryptographic
perspective about getting the right
definition
constructing a reduction I think this is
interesting
um
so here are the questions my goal is
conveying what these questions are and
the nuggets
um
okay so now we move on to tails in
average case complexity and meta
complexity
and uh here I'm going to be fairly
briefed because Holland talked about
this result yesterday
so recently here are horror showed uh
CCC
last year that there is some problem
that if you can show it's NP hard it
would eliminate the heuristic
a natural question to ask is okay is
that a problem meant to be hard no
uh at least this would show and at least
this would show that the approaches
sound you know should we expect that
problem
another problem in metacaplex is
something that I guess I asked a few
years ago uh it was about hardness and
approximation of mlcsp so it turns out
you can use obfuscation and relatives to
answer both of these questions and since
joint work with uh
discussions is yes it turns out that
hirohara's problem actually is NP hard
if you assume uh the existence of
indistinguishably obfuscation this is
not so interesting for the question of
eliminating heuristica because you can
eliminate heuristic if you already have
in this image of the obfuscation but
this is kind of like an anti
I mean anti-natural produce result like
for complexity theorists we're all sad
about cryptography in some sense because
we like kill their approach for
approving circuit lower bounds but uh
you know okay this is actually saying
okay at least at least towards
eliminating heuristica
this problem is going to be hard in fact
we pretty much already know the
reduction you know we know if you take
it I can take a candidate IO thing you
know uh if you plug that in we have the
reduction from sat to this problem uh
okay and then the second case Hamlin
talked about this yesterday the answer
is yes yes do you have any speculation
on if you can get you couldn't these
inclusive assumptions and behind itself
yeah I think that's a really good
question actually so your heart's
problem is time bad and chroma complex
conditions in a super linear setting you
can show that basically witness
encryption implies that this problem is
empty hard in the reverse Direction I'm
not sure uh it's kind of
yeah I I would I think it's really worth
uh investigating whether there's
something there's a Converse in fact a
hero Harris result that he talked about
yesterday you can think of as kind of
like a weak version of that in some
sense
since you mentioned would you actually
want to mentioned
issues oh right right right right yeah
so uh is a undergrad at uh University
and uh is he I actually get to Colombia
he's gonna make it Colombia
or yeah awesome that's great yeah it is
fantastic undergraduates
sorry sorry
okay this is all I want to say
complexity medic complexity but here are
two more areas of theoretical computer
science where IO says something about it
and so the last thing that I want to
talk about in my remaining time is uh
about differential privacy
this is kind of where maybe I'll say the
most okay so what is my where is he uh
where what is my time situation what is
it okay okay
thank you
uh so tails in different Society uh
probably you all know what differential
privacy is in this talk you know I'm not
going to assume very much about it so
differential privacy is a notion defined
by dwarf mcsherry Smith and it basically
says okay you can release information
about data with some security guarantee
and what's really nice about
differential privacy is it's like
actually like really a useful notion
it's widely used in the real world from
the Census to iOS to Google and and so
that's great one thing that's maybe not
so nice about differential privacy is
that it can be a rather restrictive
notion uh it can be quite conservative
and and this is for for many tasks there
are like lower bounds which say you
can't get differential privacy uh
with certain utility for a test which
which is uh kind of annoying and kind of
restricts adoptions
okay so how could you make differential
privacy uh more applicable how could you
get around with some of these lower
bounds well let's look at the definition
of differential privacy uh probably
everybody knows this but okay you want
to release information about data the
way that that's formalized is if you
have some randomized algorithm which
takes as input a data set and this talk
always just to pretend the data set is
over 0 1 to the end
to be generalized and uh just spits out
some information so it's just some
randomized algorithms this is the way
you release data
and it has some security guarantee uh
for the talk it's not so important what
the security guarantee is basically says
that if you flip any bid in the original
data set the answer doesn't change by
too much
but looking at this definition
you know is there anything that stands
out to you
know uh
uh stands out to you and what could be
relaxed yeah definitely I mean it's
really hidden I guess uh
if you use colors it would make it
easier
yeah yeah so as you've all said it's
physical right here
okay why your others all you're asking
about all powerful adversaries hey you
know in the real world these don't exist
um
so natural thing to Define is
computational differential privacy which
is uh which was basically defined in
these two works it's
and the definition is pretty much what
you'd expect it to be we take this
adversary a replace it by
a computational algorithm
so any questions about this
okay so what's the main question
probably the question that you'd expect
can we oh sdp here stands for
statistical differential privacy CDP
stands for computational differential
privacy so if we change our notion from
statistical differential privacy to
computational differential privacy can
we do something that we can do before in
particular for these tasks where we have
lower bounds against
um
can we can we bypass them using
computational differential types
it's a very natural question uh it's
been I guess I think this is like open
question 10.4 and uh the balance
textbook and
unfortunately at least as of 10 years
ago they're like not even candidates uh
for a separation between this and in
fact most of the prior work has been
more on the negative side there are
there are some positive results so in
the multi-party setting as we heard
about earlier uh this morning you can do
things and this is um this is because
you can do secure multi-party
computation so this is you know of
course it's a very interesting line of
research but it's not uh talking as much
about the differential privacy as it's
talking about parties coming together
and Computing things
and another word that's pretty
interesting shows that uh if you care
about efficiency actually there is a
separation between these two things
there are CDP mechanisms that are
exponentially more efficient than sdp
mechanisms for like tap like tasks for
uh for certain types of tests for
learning
right for learning so my understanding
is that this task the where you have the
efficiency
gain is only on these like kind of
contrived tests where you have to like
sign output signature kind of stuff uh
it's not not very yeah
right but I don't know if that
corresponds to the adversary being
official no it's not related to that
it's in the same style as the I mean
it's also all right the gap between
computational statistical differential
types
okay
the same question you were asked in the
morning yeah
but yeah
kind of zaps and signatures and stuff
like that maybe I miss something
dimensional tasks there is a black box
barrier saying that you you know you
can't base a separation just off of uh
random oracles or Collision resistant
hash functions or trapdoor permutation
and in fact there's actually a an
approach based on Terence Tau and Ben
Green's result of that arbitrarily large
or uh arithmetic crimes and arithmetic
congressions uh that actually if you've
been extend it to like multiple random
variables you could actually rule out
any gap between cdps
that there is uh these results
and okay let me let me just give you a
toy toy question to work with first can
you design a mechanism that is
computationally differential private but
not statistically differential private
um which seems like the question I just
asked before but there's a caveat in
fact there's a really easy answer to
this
thanks
the output here
yes exactly
it's clusters okay that's another answer
but yes I'll go with this answer which
is uh uh because I wrote it up right
yeah
uh there's a very simple mechanism which
just outputs a pseudo-random string
let's say if you have all zeros input
otherwise outputs a uniformly random
string so computationally bounded
adversary you know you can't tell the
difference between these two things but
a statistical statistical adversary
could
um
and so you'd be able to distinguish the
all zero string from something with one
one in it but you know this this isn't
very satisfying because like uh you're
actually conveying like no information
here right like you can a bounded party
can't tell can't tell any information
about D so what you have to do is you
have to like Define a task a meaningful
task with a utility or something like
that I'm not going to Define it for you
but if you like sat down and thought
about it for 30 minutes you'd probably
come up with this definition
okay
so you're saying that they can find the
example of these lines yeah and so
actually the right question you want to
ask is not can we design a mechanism M
that is CDP but not STP you want to ask
is there a
tasks
oh the contrived task is for a different
question it's about like can you get
things that are
you can do efficiently with a CDP but uh
yeah
on the next slide oh yeah
I I yeah I don't know any way to like
make presents or something well okay
maybe if you squint at this you might
sleep okay it depends yeah I would say
no
okay so what I want to tell you so this
is Joint work with Buddy gazi which is
these are people at Google uh is that
under very strong but I would say
plausible assumptions and some of these
assumptions are controversial actually
there is a task uh with a CDP mechanism
but no STP mechanism
so I'll tell you what these uh
assumptions are but I want to tell you
the Nugget first and that might lead you
to be it
okay so this is an example where you can
separate the
I'll tell you a little bit what the task
is
Okay so
what's the first idea is
what might be a class of tasks that
could separate at CDP from SCP like uh
and uh I don't know does anybody have
any ideas well the hint is the title and
maybe even a program we're in
so the idea is uh
what if you have a task
or what you're outputting
is a circuit so this is like a meta
computational thing you want a
differentially private algorithm now
puts an algorithm or a circuit
um
so this is the class of tasks that we
kind of are investigating where uh you
have to actually output a circuit
yes you think of it as a uh yeah you
could think learning would be an example
of uh this thing
good good idea
so the specific tasks that we're
interested in is something called I'll
call the N to the 0.99 distance problem
this this parameter n to the 0.99 it's
not so important don't worry about it
too much it just needs to be like a
little low then
um it's the following task you're given
some string D
and your goal is output some circuit
that accepts the
uh but rejects all strings that are uh
far from d and having distance
you might wonder okay why am I just
accepting B why can't I accept other
things that are around D okay that's
fine too this is like maybe the simplest
uh
so your goal is you're given a data set
I want to Output a circuit that kind of
tells me am I near the original data set
or not
and it turns out you can show that
there's no sdp mechanism for this as
long as your distance is like a little
over n
so now the goal is okay can you find a
computationally differential five
seconds
first and uh you know if you if you're
familiar with obfuscation then you might
first aim for a relaxed goal which is if
I only consider adversaries that you
know don't use C in a white box plate
they only run the circuit c
um
on specific inputs and look at output
pairs so this is like can you find a
mechanism that's secure against
adversaries with black box access to see
this is like a weaker thing and then you
know if you can accomplish this relaxed
goal obfuscation could hopefully bring
you from the relaxed goal uh to the CDP
so that's so that's the approach
some promise problems right
is it a promise from I don't think I
know I think it's a total problem
I'm saying the guarantee that it needs
to satisfy his promise there's a gap in
it but uh
does this make sense is there any
questions
yes Russell so why is it difficult for
us because
so
the type you can okay so just
information theoretically
the fact that you're outputting a
circuit doesn't really matter yeah
so why can't you say oh I'm definitely
gonna I'll put my screen
and then I'm just going to like slowly
fade off
yeah and so what you can show actually
is that like pretty much the only thing
you can do is like randomized
responsibility like uh uh or take a
okay maybe I don't want to get into the
lower bound but it turns out that by the
way you Fade Out you have to fade out
like kind of centered around the point
and this is what's going to kill you
this is how you'll be able to like
depending on how you figure out there's
going to be kind of like a Center Point
okay but yeah yeah
we can I can talk to you about it later
okay did anybody have an idea for how
you might get a magnificent secure
against
so you you have this task I want to
Output a circuit that accepts things
that are close to D rejects things that
are far from d and I want to make sure
if you only make a polynomial number of
queries that you can't
um
how whether I started from D or D Prime
numbers
specifically about a point you're
supposed to accept it uh if you ask out
a point you either will say yes or no
but if it says
okay I'll play randomized Focus
uh let's say no but maybe you can if you
don't okay
can you open a distribution well I guess
if you had a distribution of seconds
then
I mean your algorithm is fun yeah
okay so it seems like Builder yet has an
idea which I don't either uh if you have
an idea this is like a very nice list
this is just a question query complexity
right like uh you know can you output a
set such that if you make a polynomial
number of course for it you know you can
be differentially private so this is
just a query complexity question I don't
know how to answer I actually think that
this should be a question that should be
answerable but I don't know how to do it
but you can show interestingly or maybe
at first not so interestingly that there
is a mechanism secure against
non-adaptive query adversaries so if if
the query adversary isn't allowed to
make adaptive queries to your circuit
then you can be secure
and so here's the final nugget I want to
convey you know you what I've told you
is that there is a mechanism that secure
against non-adapt uh adversaries making
non-adaptive queries to see
originally the plan was use obfuscation
to turn this into a mechanism secure
against
adaptive Turing machines or circuit
adversaries
so the natural way to do it is to take C
and obfuscate it that was the original
plan pretty much
but this you know
obviously won't work
except that it kind of does uh because
the reason why it shouldn't I obviously
shouldn't work is that like here you
have security against adversaries making
non-adaptive queries to see after you
obfuscate it and hand it to an adversary
you know they can make whatever queries
they want to it they can make adaptive
queries to it obviously it won't work
anybody know have an idea for what might
make it work I mean you have to do a
trick obviously
so
randomize the
between the major query
randomly reinterpreted
yeah well okay something along those
lines so the idea is you actually have
to combine
uh your original mechanism with keyless
Collision resistant hash functions and
deferring inputs obfuscation so there's
some way to actually use keyless
Collision resistant hash functions to
force the adversary to be non-adaptive
keyless Collision resistant hash
functions
you know I'm not I haven't told you what
they are but morally what they do is
they say anybody who knows that uh
something that hashes to the zero string
needs to memorize it somehow this is
kind of like being non-adaptive and uh
deferring into the obfuscation is
something we need to have a uh our
mechanism play nice with this thing
um
actually interestingly it's like the the
specific type of eio that we need is
like seems to be like much weaker than
like uh almost any other application of
the i o that we've seen secure even in
with no auxiliary input even like a
public coin sample Bowl thing so it's
kind of anyway
um and so it turns out what you have to
do is you have to modify the problem uh
where you basically you will only
consider data sets which hash to zero
under the hash function and you know
there's a lot of details to go through
but the Nugget I want to convey is you
can do this kind of surprising thing
which I think should have more
applications
which is you can turn a non-adaptive
query separation into something that's
kind of adaptive which seems at first to
be not make sense but uh
and so thanks for listening uh the
summary of this talk is like how about
participation there are these questions
in this various areas I think uh you
know
there should be more applications of
application and yeah thank you very much
thank you
really Enlightenment yes
so
okay I still don't get how it is what
you were suggesting
the result you were after how we differ
from my name is angry result in learning
are considered hard to learn
you can learn if you don't care about
privacy
but you cannot learn a
you can learn inefficiently if you do
care about privacy we can learn
efficiently to care about privacy
so I'm I'm not so familiar with this
paper maybe we can look at it
he's interested in the distinction
between computational privacy and
statistical privacy they're doing no
privacy versus
so you cannot get a
oh you're saying so there is you're
saying there is no no
there's no privacy no privacy Theory